Shure: 6
Jake:four
Jake: four
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 卧槽这个他妈的
Shure: Damn, this is freaking
Nicous: areyouok
Nicous: are you ok
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross shoulders, shoulders cross
Shure: 这几个关节好像2哒3哒45678 哇
Shure: These joints seem like 2, 3, 45678, wow
Lucia: 臀体拳预备
Lucia: Prepare for hip punch
Shure: 还扎马步
Shure: Still in horse stance
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Is Zhang Yuying spinning?
Shure: 不行这真不会啊
Shure: No, I really can't do this
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 这怎么讲
Katrina: How do you say this?
Nicous: 卧槽
Nicous: Damn
Tasha: 难度不对吧
Tasha: Isn't the difficulty off?
Nicous: soesea
Shure: 这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this 0.5x speed?
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: Oh my
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 哎好快这一边
Lucia: Wow, this side is so fast
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Nicous: 不行了不行了
Nicous: I can't, I can't
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's try again
Katrina: 先把前两部分
Katrina: First, the first two parts
Katrina: 啊哈
Katrina: Aha
Jake:再来一次再来一次
Jake: Again, again
Shure: 脑
Shure: Brain
Katrina: 把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts
Alice:我们
Alice: We
Jake:来
Jake: Come on
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure: 脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain is going to explode
Katrina: 手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone, rewind it a bit
Jake:放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Katrina: 你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Do you want to record us with the music we just had?
Katrina: 还是从头
Katrina: Or from the start?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just do a complete dance from the beginning.
Shure: 那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Then let's show everyone the first part.
Shure: 我们跳的最好的这一部分吧
Shure: The part we dance the best.
Katrina: 额可以
Katrina: Uh, okay.
Jake:全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera.
Jake:就是相当于这边处一人看你们
Jake: It's like someone from this side watching you.
Shure: OK准备好了吗rady
Shure: Okay, are you ready?
Nicous: 其实已经忘记了
Nicous: Actually, I already forgot.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two-two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 三二三四五六七八
Shure: Three-two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 四二三四跑二三起
Shure: Four-two-three-four-run-two-three-up.
Shure: 一二三四张二收
Shure: One-two-three-four-open-two-close.
Shure: 二三二三四甩二三滑
Shure: Two-three-two-three-four-sway-two-three-slide.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two-two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch-two-heart-pose-open.
Shure: 二三走一二
Shure: Two-three-walk-one-two.
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 一二三四五六七八
Shure: One-two-three-four-five-six-seven-eight.
Shure: 踏步二一二三四
Shure: Step-two-one-two-three-four.
Shure: 一二三四跑
Shure: One-two-three-four-run.
Shure: 跳二三四
Shure: Jump-two-three-four.
Shure: 张二收二三四划二三四
Shure: Open-two-close-two-three-four-slide-two-three-four.
Shure: 摸手二三四顶二三四
Shure: Touch-hand-two-three-four-push-two-three-four.
Shure: 二三四一二三停
Shure: Two-three-four-one-two-three-stop.
Lucia: 又卡帧了
Lucia: The frame froze again.
Shure: 简单
Shure: Simple.
Katrina: 第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure: 来第二部分
Shure: Let's do the second part.
Shure: 再跟他过一遍
Shure: Go over it again with him.
Nicous: 直接0.75
Nicous: Go straight to 0.75.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 直接0.75
Katrina: Go straight to 0.75.
Nicous: 没有直接可以第一和第二节连起来
Nicous: We can directly link the first and second sections.
Katrina: 哇你就这么自信的吗
Katrina: Wow, are you really that confident?
Jake:这是OK
Jake: This is okay.
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: These three parts together...
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: It doesn't seem to add up to the full duration.
Lucia: 那就从头单曲循环
Lucia: Then let's just loop the song from the start.
Shure: 一二三四二二三四一二甩
Shure: One two three four, two two three four, one two sway.
Shure: 二张二开二一二三四
Shure: Two open, two one two three four.
Lucia: 等一下太快了
Lucia: Wait, that's too fast.
Shure: 41234223412
Shure: 41234223412.
Shure: 最后一二三四五六七八
Shure: Finally, one two three four five six seven eight.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight.
Shure: 转胯三四五六拍拍
Shure: Hip turn three four five six clap.
Shure: 一二三四五六七停
Shure: One two three four five six seven stop.
Lucia: 我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: I think we should practice the second part more.
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: We need to sync the hand and foot movements.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Nicous: 不行太
Nicous: No, it's too...
Jake:好好下一个环节
Jake: Okay, next segment.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 下一个环节
Katrina: Next segment.
Jake:记得花
Jake: Remember the flower.
Katrina: 哦哦哦你说行行
Katrina: Oh, right, right, got it.
Jake:行吧好好好行
Jake: Okay, alright, alright.
Nicous: 挑个心动的一个人咋俩吃吧
Nicous: Let's pick someone we like to eat with.
Shure: 这是谁呀呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Shure: Who is this, who is this, who is this?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:都录着了
Jake: It's all recorded.
Jake:啊哈哈好
Jake: Ahaha, good.
Katrina: 行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go pick a flower.
Shure: 他的出镜率不比他来的出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time isn't less than his, right?
Jake:对我们第第7位选手
Jake: Yes, our 7th contestant.
Katrina: 几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哦 4点了
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock.
Katrina: 是不是也得准备菜啥的啊
Katrina: Shouldn't we start preparing the dishes too?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina: 那就选一下花
Katrina: Then let's pick a flower.
Jake:对拧个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking a flower is our activity.
Jake:我们可以再给你跟跟剧组讲解一下的
Jake: We can give you and the crew an explanation.
Jake:一些
Jake: About some things.
Jake:也不是就是可能是7天
Jake: Well, it's not that, maybe it's 7 days.
Katrina: 确实好容易出汗啊
Katrina: It's really easy to sweat.
Katrina: 你别说有的女团舞特别累
Katrina: You know, some girl group dances are really tiring.
Katrina: 就是你知道那个HIPPOP里有
Katrina: Like, you know in those hippop, there's...
Katrina: 有个团叫那个itzye
Katrina: There's a group called ITZY.
Katrina: 她们的舞跳下来就是半条命都没有
Katrina: Their dances are so intense, you feel like you're half dead after.
小黄: 半条命都没了
Nicous: Half dead, really.
Katrina: 对真的很累
Katrina: Yeah, it's really exhausting.
Nicous: 然后内个啥
Nicous: And then, um...
Katrina: 咳咳咳咳咳阿斯克咳咳咳andtakeinboy
Katrina: *cough cough* ask *cough cough* and take in boy
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically,
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: how you dance in the end isn't that important.
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据
Lucia: Right, as long as we have the data.
Katrina: 写一下名字簿
Katrina: Write the names down.
Katrina: 然后贴挑一束花
Katrina: Then pick a bouquet.
Katrina: 然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: And take pictures of it every day.
Nicous: 这么牛逼
Nicous: That's impressive.
Katrina: 对因为有了花苞
Katrina: Yeah, because it has buds.
Katrina: 这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: They will gradually bloom.
Katrina: 写名字写名字贴
Katrina: Write the names, stick them on.
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the names.
Jake:写名字写呗
Jake: Write the names, go ahead.
Katrina: 那这我挑了
Katrina: I'll pick this one.
Shure: 谁让你跳的呵呵呵
Shure: Who told you to pick it? Haha.
Katrina: 偷偷挑的
Katrina: I secretly picked it.
Katrina: 挑是最好的
Katrina: Picking is the best.
Katrina: 今晚上还可以再练
Katrina: We can practice again tonight.
Jake:哎你你俩有
Jake: Hey, you two...
Jake:有你俩事
Jake: You two have something.
Jake:你俩在打
Jake: You two are fighting.
Jake:我出去来
Jake: I'm stepping out.
Katrina: 我的草莓种
Katrina: My strawberries are growing.
Jake:到位了啊兄弟们到位了
Jake: Alright guys, we're all set.
Tasha: 嗯哦
Tasha: Mm, oh.
Tasha: 这有人了
Tasha: Someone's here.
Tasha: 名花有主了
Tasha: The flower has an owner now.
Katrina: 这是要泡几分钟
Katrina: How long should we soak this?
Lucia: 有他应该是还没开
Lucia: It hasn't bloomed yet.
Lucia: 就是应该各种就里面都都放了
Lucia: We should put various kinds inside.
Alice:应该只有一个
Alice: There should only be one.
Katrina: 都都放了芍药的球球
Katrina: Put the peony bulbs inside.
Katrina: 等它慢慢开就行
Katrina: Just let them bloom slowly.
Katrina: 对这些都是芍药球
Katrina: Yes, these are all peony bulbs.
Katrina: 芍药开出
Katrina: Peonies bloom...
Lucia: 啊我可以写了哎
Lucia: Ah, I can write now.
Katrina: 来好大呀
Katrina: Come on, it's so big.
Lucia: 笔上哪去了在这
Lucia: Where did the pen go? Here it is.
Katrina: 自己房间装饰
Katrina: Decorate your own room.
Shure: 来来来让一下
Shure: Come on, move aside.
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: You can incorporate it into our room decoration.
Katrina: 你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also place it somewhere in the living room.
Katrina: 都行反正你自己管着
Katrina: Whatever, you take care of it.
Katrina: 他每天要拍照
Katrina: He needs to take photos every day.
Nicous: 每天要拍照片
Nicous: He needs to take photos every day.
Katrina: 哎呀老学我的口音干什么
Katrina: Oh my, why are you imitating my accent?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈可以放外面播
Katrina: Hahaha, you can put it outside to broadcast.
Katrina: 他需要那个光合作用吗
Katrina: It needs sunlight for photosynthesis.
Shure: 外面不好吧
Shure: Outside isn't good, right?
Katrina: 就是生物钟
Katrina: It's the biological clock.
Katrina: 他们是需要进行光合作用好像
Katrina: They seem to need photosynthesis.
Katrina: 但是也不能长时间进行光合作用
Katrina: But they can't photosynthesize for too long.
Katrina: 你还记得吗
Katrina: Do you remember?
Katrina: 好像会那个什么死掉
Katrina: They seem to die from it.
Katrina: 就是那个气口
Katrina: It's the stomata.
Shure: 蒸腾作用过的
Shure: They over-transpire.
Katrina: 对对真疼
Katrina: Yes, yes, over-transpire.
Lucia: 灯也是可以的吗
Lucia: Can the lamp work too?
Shure: 你看看这脑子
Shure: Look at this brain.
Katrina: 就是有文化
Katrina: So knowledgeable.
Lucia: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Lucia: Hmm, why is one broken?
Katrina: ;断了么哦
Katrina: Broken? Oh.
Shure: Dyson i need a corporation
Shure: Dyson, I need a corporation.
Jake:哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 这个放哪呢
Shure: Where should we put this?
Shure: 我那面是阴面不宜养花
Shure: My side is shady, not suitable for growing flowers.
Katrina: 天呐垃圾成堆
Katrina: Oh my god, piles of trash.
Jake:不是是跟他一样
Jake: It's not, it's the same as his.
Katrina: 看我衣服干
Katrina: Look, my clothes are dry.
Katrina: tonight tonight
Jake:敲完了吗大伙
Jake: Are you all done knocking?
Alice:你贴了吗
Alice: Did you stick it?
Jake:对啊我也觉得
Jake: Yeah, I think so too.
Jake:你拿下来了
Jake: Did you take it down?
Jake:那你放哪去
Jake: So where did you put it?
Tasha: 最里面那个
Tasha: The one in the very back.
Katrina: 今天拍照
Katrina: Let's take some photos today.
Katrina: 还有球球吗
Katrina: Is there still the ball?
Lucia: 今天的照片我把它放哪拍呢
Lucia: Where should I take today's photos?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 看看芍药需要几天才能开花
Katrina: Let's see how many days it takes for the peonies to bloom.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Jake:幸亏他们买的是可乐
Jake: Luckily, they boucht cola.
Alice:让我给他修剪一下
Alice: Let me trim it a bit.
Lucia: 有一点点背光
Lucia: It's a bit backlit.
Jake:挑好了吗
Jake: Have you picked one?
Katrina: 调好了
Katrina: Yes, I've adjusted it.
Alice:这个是可以剪花的
Alice: This one can be cut.
Jake:给我留的哪个呀
Jake: Which one did you leave for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个剪
Tasha: How about using the one from yesterday?
Katrina: 是不是最里面那个这个
Katrina: Is it the one in the very back?
Alice:昨天那个在哪
Alice: Where's the one from yesterday?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:这什么花呀
Jake: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina: 这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina: 这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This should also be a peony.
Katrina: 这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina: 然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Alice:哎剪子在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 就买了这几种
Katrina: We only bought these kinds.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here they are.
Alice:剪花的那个
Alice: The flower-cutting ones.
Shure: 我给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: I'll give my flower a name.
Katrina: sunshine好土
Katrina: Sunshine is so cheesy.
Katrina: 你可以叫sunshine或者叫smile
Katrina: You can call it Sunshine or Smile.
Shure: smart可还行
Shure: Smart would be okay.
Katrina: 微笑
Katrina: Smile.
Jake:酒店
Jake: Hotel.
Jake:这个不能乱关
Jake: Don't turn this off randomly.
Jake:所以关了硬盘就会好
Jake: So if you turn it off, the hard drive will be fine.
Jake:然后搞成这个样子
Jake: And then it ended up like this.
Jake:血汗工厂开店
Jake: Sweatshop opening soon.
Jake:thrill
Jake: Thrill.
Jake:你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go in.
Jake:这这两个给你们
Jake: These two are for you.
Katrina: 哇好像那是自习室啊
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a study room.
Jake:这
Jake: This...
Katrina: 就是那补习班
Katrina: It's like a tutoring center.
Jake:哎呦让我出去
Jake: Oh, let me out.
Katrina: 然后现在推门进去减负
Katrina: And now you open the door to reduce the burden.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Jake:血汗工厂
Jake: Sweatshop.
Katrina: 不准办补习班
Katrina: No tutoring centers allowed.
Lucia: 不可翻译
Lucia: Can't translate that.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太搞笑了
Katrina: Hahaha, that's so funny.
Jake:不准办公
Jake: No office work allowed.
Lucia: 不准翻弓
Lucia: No bow translation.
Jake:禁止办公
Jake: Office work is forbidden.
Jake:这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Let's stick a "No office work" sign here.
Lucia: 这标这标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this slogan.
Katrina: 拍拍坐像那种
Katrina: Take a picture, like that.
Shure: 你们你们仨是网吧
Shure: Are you three in an internet cafe?
Shure: 3连坐是吗
Shure: Three in a row, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的像
Katrina: Hahaha, it really looks like it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪
Lucia: Is this table outside a bit crooked?
Lucia: 这个板
Lucia: This board.
Lucia: 不是就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: No, I mean the board doesn't seem very flat.
Jake:对对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Lucia: 对对对是平时不够哦OK
Lucia: Yeah, it's not usually flat. Oh, okay.
Jake:他就是不够
Jake: It just isn't flat.
Jake:哈哈哈很勉强
Jake: Hahaha, very makeshift.
Jake:不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's fine, this will do.
Shure: 你们仨准备打点什么
Shure: What are you three planning to play?
Shure: 英雄联盟吗
Shure: League of Legends?
Jake:三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me with this.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Alice:斗地主
Alice: Playing Dou Di Zhu
Lucia: 三个人
Lucia: Three people
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me hold this
Shure: 三个人APEX
Shure: Three people in APEX
Lucia: 三个人可以
Lucia: Three people can
Lucia: 三个人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed Black Flag online
Shure: 可以永结无间
Shure: We can have eternal bonds
Jake:好好好行了行了
Jake: Okay, okay, that's enough
Shure: 这时候赶紧给我们的网易打个广告
Shure: This is a good time to advertise our NetEase game
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good
Jake:这样好
Jake: This is good
Shure: 这是干嘛的呀
Shure: What's this for?
Lucia: 做引体向上的哈哈哈
Lucia: For doing pull-ups, haha
Katrina: 做引体销售
Katrina: For doing pull-up sales
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吗
Shure: Hang a bar and do pull-ups, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes
Jake:行行行挺好挺好
Jake: Okay, okay, pretty good, pretty good
Shure: 能能成功吗
Shure: Can you do it?
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good, pretty good
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We're just kidding
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful
Shure: 主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't pull myself up
Shure: 需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Do we need to trim this?
Katrina: 随便你你的话
Katrina: It's up to you
Lucia: 你想修的话可以修呀
Lucia: If you want to trim it, you can
Jake:也不用那么高
Jake: It doesn't need to be that high
Shure: 我不修因为我姓
Shure: I won't trim it because I'm...
Jake:就你就卡到这就行
Jake: Just stop here, it's fine
Shure: 修了一下
Shure: Trimmed a bit
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh
Alice:不缺修
Alice: No need to trim
Jake:高了我怕他摔
Jake: If it's too high, I'm afraid he'll fall
Jake:你看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed
Lucia: 为什么这几个球球到现在还没有开
Lucia: Why aren't these balls opened yet?
Jake:全自动全自动入口你说
Jake: Fully automated entrance, you said
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my god
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you come over?
Jake:哈哈哈能啊这个一跳我就上上床
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, with one jump, I can get on the bed.
Shure: 这么大地儿
Shure: So big!
Jake:对上床入口
Jake: Yes, the bed entrance.
Shure: 我靠哎呦喂sorry
Shure: Damn, oh my, sorry.
Lucia: sorry一跳就上床了可还行
Lucia: Sorry, just one jump and get on the bed
Jake:对哈哈对对对入口
Jake: Yes, haha, yes, yes, the entrance.
Katrina: 嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Hmm, the ideal room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈学习完倒头就睡
Katrina: Hahaha, after studying, you can just fall asleep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:饶了我吧哈哈哈
Jake: Spare me, hahaha.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 这个确实是软件工程李小忠的房间了
Lucia: This is definitely the room of software engineer Li Xiaozhong.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对写完代码直接倒头就睡
Katrina: Yeah, after writing code, you can just fall asleep.
Jake:哎盘呢
Jake: Hey, where's the disk?
Lucia: 啊哪哪个
Lucia: Ah, which one?
Jake:哦哦哦对对对刚刚对刚刚
Jake: Oh, oh, yeah, the one just now.
Lucia: 刚拿过来的这个吗
Lucia: The one we just brought over?
Katrina: 哎二楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: Hey, the projector on the second floor is good too.
Katrina: 那款放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music on that model?
Jake:对易老也是
Jake: Yeah, Yi Lao also.
Shure: 来电music
Shure: Play some music.
Katrina: yes反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Yes, anyway, we're wearing glasses.
Jake:来点music
Jake: Play some music.
Katrina: 已经录下来
Katrina: It's already recorded.
Jake:你们你们要现在是要干啥呀按照
Jake: What are you guys going to do now?
Katrina: 我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We can discuss.
Katrina: 我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: Our room decoration.
Katrina: 你不说要录录录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you wanted to record it?
Jake:对对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yes, yes, and then they should...
Jake:他说是4五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone will come to clean around 4 or 5.
Jake:对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yes, and then we'll clean.
Jake:收拾完我们就扫房间
Jake: After cleaning, we'll clean the room.
Jake:就是扫3D层
Jake: clean 3D floor.
Jake:嗯对我靠
Jake: Hmm, yeah, damn.
Jake:4399 呵呵呵
Jake: 4399, hehehe.
Katrina: 那几点准备食材呢
Katrina: When should we prepare the ingredients?
Jake:呃对那要不现在就开始准备食材吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, why not start preparing the ingredients now?
Shure: 死神vs火影
Shure: Death vs. Naruto.
Shure: 这不得来一把
Shure: Shouldn't we give it a try?
Jake:然后
Jake: Then
Jake:对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yeah, let's start preparing the ingredients now.
Jake:就现在就看一看
Jake: Let's just take a look now.
Jake:准备准备
Jake: Get ready.
Katrina: 现在也可以看那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: We can also look at buying room decorations now.
Jake:也可以
Jake: Sure, we can.
Katrina: 然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: Then at 5 o'clock, he'll come to clean and sweep the room.
Katrina: 我们只需要稍微
Katrina: We just need to tidy up a bit.
Katrina: 收拾一下我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Then we'll come down and handle this.
Katrina: 对扫房间
Katrina: Yeah, sweeping the room.
Katrina: 扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: You three are doing the room sweeping, right?
Jake:呃这打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, is it the room cleaning?
Katrina: 需要我们辅助么
Katrina: Do you need our help?
Jake:嗯不用不用
Jake: No, no.
Jake:我们都不用弄
Jake: We don't need to do anything.
Katrina: OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then we'll...
Tasha: 是那你先放也行
Tasha: You can put it down first if you want.
Katrina: 我看我要买什么
Katrina: Let me see what I need to buy.
Jake:OK来关掉4399
Jake: OK, let's turn off 4399.
Katrina: 我想买那我想搞成那种森林主题
Katrina: I want to buy something. I want to go for a forest theme.
Jake:然后那个上上卡
Jake: Then upload the card.
Lucia: 我我没想好我要怎么样
Lucia: I haven't decided what I want yet.
Katrina: 搞全绿色
Katrina: Go all green.
Tasha: allright
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 我想我想借一个同学的作业抄一下
Lucia: I want to borrow a classmate's homework to copy.
Katrina: 还有
Katrina: And
Alice:我本来想弄蓝的
Alice: I originally wanted to go with blue.
Katrina: 也可
Katrina: That's fine too.
Alice:后来发现蓝的太难买
Alice: But then I found blue is too hard to get.
Tasha: allright
Tasha: Alright.
Alice:然后昨天晚上也挑了绿的
Alice: So last night I picked green.
Katrina: 以
Katrina: Oh
Katrina: 也可以搞那种极简的
Katrina: You could go for something minimalist too.
Jake:为什么是这个
Jake: Why is that?
Katrina: 就那种无印良品风也行吧
Katrina: Like the Muji style could work too.
Alice:我先找一堆绿的我喜欢
Alice: I'll first find a bunch of green that I like.
Katrina: 你房间有那个钩子吗
Katrina: Do you have hooks in your room?
Alice:青一点的绿
Alice: A lighter green.
Katrina: 就是我房间有两个钩子
Katrina: I have two hooks in my room.
Katrina: 我感觉可以买那种挂画海报呢
Katrina: I feel like we could buy some hanging posters.
Katrina: 因为他不给贴
Katrina: Because he won't let us stick them on.
Shure: 这样吧我们建一个歌单
Shure: How about this, let's create a playlist.
Shure: 然后大家一人报一个歌名好吧
Shure: And everyone can suggest a song, okay?
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Exactly, exactly.
Katrina: 大家可以想听什么自己输进去
Katrina: Everyone can input whatever song they want to listen to.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 然后我们搞随机播放
Katrina: And then we can shuffle play it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哇有点像那个随机舞蹈了哈哈
Katrina: Wow, it's kind of like a random dance, haha.
Shure: 来大家先一人说一个歌名
Shure: Alright, everyone suggest a song first.
Shure: 我先都不放
Shure: I won't play anything yet.
Shure: 然后都加到歌单里
Shure: We'll add them all to the playlist.
Shure: 然后这个歌单随便放可以吧
Shure: And then we can play the playlist randomly, okay?
Katrina: 上想听的歌
Katrina: Add the songs you want to hear.
Lucia: 我打开我的apple music
Lucia: I'll open my Apple Music.
Katrina: 好有意思啊
Katrina: This is so interesting.
Lucia: 然后突然发现
Lucia: And then I suddenly realized...
Tasha: 全部一股脑塞进来
Tasha: Put them all in at once.
Lucia: 我的我的APP账号没登在里面
Lucia: My app account isn't logged in.
Jake:我操没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: Oh shoot, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 所以找不到自己签的歌单了
Lucia: So I can't find the playlist I signed in.
Katrina: 好有好有意思
Katrina: This is so interesting.
Lucia: 我得重新登录一下
Lucia: I need to log in again.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I think...
Shure: 你要什么
Shure: What do you want?
Katrina: 来一首那个陶喆的爱很简单
Katrina: Let's play David Tao's "Love is Simple".
Jake:11号
Jake: Number 11.
Shure: 爱很简单真的吗
Shure: "Love is Simple", really?
Tasha: 嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 哇这首歌每次都是演唱会的压轴
Katrina: Wow, this song is always the finale at concerts.
Shure: 陶喆
Shure: David Tao.
Jake:1号没人
Jake: No one at number 1.
Shure: 哦好像
Shure: Oh, it seems...
Jake:换换下来就是这个
Jake: Let's switch to this.
Katrina: 肯定听过
Katrina: You've definitely heard it.
Jake:看看有没有
Jake: Let's see if we have it.
Shure: 不是没有陶喆版本
Shure: There's no David Tao version.
Jake:东西万一要是原来送一个256
Jake: In case we originally gave a 256.
Katrina: 啊你没有VIP是吗
Katrina: Oh, you don't have VIP, do you?
Shure: 啊这个带的都好
Shure: Ah, this all looks good.
Shure: 好先不慌
Shure: Okay, don't rush.
Shure: 先加入歌单
Shure: Add it to the playlist first.
Shure: 收藏一个
Shure: Save it as a favorite.
Katrina: 等会等会
Katrina: Wait, wait.
Katrina: 这样拍张照好好
Katrina: Take a picture like this, it's good.
Katrina: 有那种综艺的感觉
Katrina: It has that variety show feel.
Shure: 是的还有什么
Shure: Yes, what else?
Lucia: 我我我点那个打雷姐的video games
Lucia: I, I, I want to play that video game by Lana Del Rey.
Shure: VEDD啊VIDD UVM
Shure: VEDD, VIDD, UVM.
Katrina: 海报一直没挑好不知道挑什么没什么好看的
Katrina: The poster still not choosed, I don't know what to choose. There's nothing good.
Shure: 这个是什么
Shure: What's this?
Lucia: 拉娜德雷的对
Lucia: Lana Del Rey's, yes.
Jake:这电脑有吗
Jake: Does this computer have it?
Jake:一样
Jake: The same.
Jake:右边没有吗
Jake: Isn't it on the right?
Shure: 还有人吗
Shure: Is anyone else there?
Lucia: 然后还有什么
Lucia: What else?
Jake:不是不是他
Jake: Not, not him.
Alice:蝴蝶
Alice: Butterfly.
Jake:你左边没有吗
Jake: Isn't it on your left?
Shure: 蝴蝶谁的
Shure: Whose butterfly?
Katrina: 谁的蝴蝶
Katrina: Whose butterfly?
Alice:淘集集
Alice: Taobao.
Katrina: 你也喜欢这首歌吗
Katrina: Do you like this song too?
Alice:我挺喜欢的
Alice: I quite like it.
Katrina: 这是我超喜欢的一首歌
Katrina: This is one of my favorite songs.
Katrina: 我当时当时分手的时候狂听这首歌
Katrina: I listened to this a lot when I broke up.
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake:我毫无encounter呢
Jake: I have no encounter.
Lucia: 诶薇薇呢
Lucia: Hey, where's Vivi?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh man.
Alice:上去收拾东西喽
Alice: Go upstairs and pack up.
Jake:毫无encounter
Jake: No encounter.
Lucia: 啊她还没有报报歌
Lucia: Ah, she hasn't reported the song yet.
Katrina: 当这世界已经准备着
Katrina: When this world is ready.
Katrina: 我可以多多搞一场
Katrina: I can do more.
Katrina: 搞那个我最近喜欢听那个张璇的
Katrina: Do that, I've been liking Zhang Xuan's songs recently.
Shure: 我的宝贝宝贝
Shure: My baby, baby.
Katrina: 搞他的那个焰火
Katrina: Do his "Fireworks".
Katrina: 你你要跳舞吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Do you want to dance? Hahaha
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 最出圈的是吧
Shure: The most popular one, right?
Jake:那个应该是被我清掉了
Jake: That should have been removed by me.
Jake:但是很蠢
Jake: But it's really silly.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Katrina: 我刚说的是什么
Katrina: What did I just say?
Lucia: 我点一个音乐剧里面的
Lucia: I'll pick one from the musical.
Katrina: 不知道说什么
Katrina: I don't know what to say.
Katrina: 我感觉我的记忆有点
Katrina: I feel like my memory is a bit...
Katrina: 就是7秒钟不知道说什么
Katrina: Like, I can't remember what to say for 7 seconds.
Shure: 嗨嗨没有他是这么拼的吧
Shure: Hi, hi, isn't it spelled like this?
Lucia: 对的对的对
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's right.
Shure: 这个是吧
Shure: Is this it?
Shure: 对就就开场焰火
Shure: Yes, it's the opening fireworks.
Lucia: 就就开场那首吧
Lucia: Yeah, the opening song.
Katrina: 焰火
Katrina: Fireworks.
Shure: 焰火
Shure: Fireworks.
Shure: 还有人要点歌吗
Shure: Does anyone else want to request a song?
Lucia: 有人要点歌吗
Lucia: Anyone want to request a song?
Lucia: 3位要点歌吗
Lucia: Do you three want to request a song?
Jake:那不知羞硕的事情吗点歌
Jake: Isn't it Shure's thing to request songs?
Lucia: 点歌
Lucia: Request a song.
Lucia: 不是要放是要弹
Lucia: Not to play, but to perform.
Shure: 陈翔的吗
Shure: Chen Xiang's?
Shure: 还是郭泰杰的
Shure: Or Guo Taijie's?
Katrina: 艳艳丽的艳焰火张
Katrina: Bright and brilliant fireworks.
Shure: 啊安普啊呜
Shure: Ah, An Pu, ah woo.
Katrina: 最近很喜欢他
Katrina: I've really liked him recently.
Katrina: 就是晚上一个人把那个
Katrina: Just at night, alone, listening to that...
Katrina: 但是这房间隔音不太好
Katrina: But the soundproofing in this room isn't great.
Katrina: 估计大家也听到放那个歌特好听
Katrina: I guess everyone can hear that song, it's really nice.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Jake:呃首先这个东西它在它是
Jake: Uh, first of all, this thing, it is...
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's leave it at that.
Shure: 安抚还
Shure: An Pu still...
Katrina: 我看好像是安普
Katrina: I think it's An Pu.
Katrina: 呀涉及到知识
Katrina: Ah, it involves knowledge.
Shure: 是安抚这个字
Shure: It is the character "An Pu."
Katrina: 网球查一下吧
Katrina: Let's look it up online.
Jake:这个这个给我
Jake: This, this, give it to me.
Katrina: 是念谱吧
Katrina: Are we reading sheet music?
Katrina: 啊这首好听
Katrina: Ah, this song is nice.
Shure: 这前两天刚回归网易云
Shure: This just got back on NetEase Cloud a few days ago.
Jake:不管他然后你你这边手上是什么
Jake: Doesn't matter, then what do you have in your hands?
Lucia: 那我点那个滚石的
Lucia: Then I'll pick the one by The Rolling Stones.
Lucia: 不是滚石枪花的希文沃
Lucia: No, wait, the one by Guns N' Roses, it's "November Rain."
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈超喜欢这个
Lucia: Haha, I really love this one.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh wow.
Lucia: 突然想起来
Lucia: Just remembered.
Jake:行这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do this.
Jake:就是你这二楼的
Jake: You're handling the second floor.
Shure: 这才是老摇滚
Shure: This is real old rock.
Jake:呃视频主搞一楼的好吧
Jake: Uh, video guy, you handle the first floor, okay?
Lucia: 经常在听老歌
Lucia: I often listen to old songs.
Katrina: 好有意思
Katrina: So interesting.
Katrina: 大家的风格都完全不一样
Katrina: Everyone's style is completely different.
Jake:VLC VLC VLC VLC啊
Jake: VLC VLC VLC VLC, yeah.
Shure: 谁刚刚没有点歌来着要点歌
Shure: Who hasn't picked a song yet? Pick a song.
Lucia: 微微点歌吗
Lucia: Tasha, are you picking a song?
Katrina: 他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: He picked "Butterfly."
Katrina: 哦那个我也点过
Katrina: Oh, I also picked that one.
Shure: 蝴蝶点过了
Shure: "Butterfly" has been picked.
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Mm, right.
Lucia: 你还你还你
Lucia: You still, you still, you...
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: Haven't picked yet, right?
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't picked?
Katrina: 有啥想听的歌不
Katrina: Is there a song you want to hear?
Tasha: 路亚要点一首是吗
Tasha: Lua, you want to pick a song, right?
Lucia: 对也可以多点
Lucia: Yes, you can pick more.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:这边要点陈奕迅
Jake: Over here, pick an Eason Chan song.
Lucia: 两首可以点哪个浮夸
Lucia: You can pick two, like "Exaggerate."
Katrina: 来首陈奕迅的
Katrina: Let's have an Eason Chan song.
Tasha: 我手机呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 周杰伦没有我是
Shure: No Jay Chou? I'm...
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 陈奕迅和周杰伦
Lucia: Eason Chan and Jay Chou.
Katrina: 我想听那个爱是一本书
Katrina: I want to hear that song "Love is a Book"
Katrina: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Katrina: The one by Eason Chan, "Love is a Book"
Shure: 是一本书OK
Shure: "Love is a Book", OK
Jake:哎你这怎么
Jake: Hey, what's up
Jake:你看咋的
Jake: What are you looking at
Lucia: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个
Lucia: I also want to request an Eason Chan song
Jake:哎呦哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh wow, oh wow, damn
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:卧槽你你是几天没睡觉的
Jake: Damn, how many days haven't you slept?
Shure: OK先
Shure: OK, first
Katrina: 还有还有内个葡萄也好听
Katrina: And also that song "Grape" is nice too
Jake:呃你你等啊
Jake: Uh, wait a second
Jake:你你拧一下
Jake: Can you twist it
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:拧一下你拧一下
Jake: Twist it, twist it
Jake:好你你是谁
Jake: Alright, who are you
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What do you want to do
Jake:OK你现在电脑里面
Jake: OK, now on your computer
Katrina: 这是什么软件
Katrina: What software is this
Jake:你你现在电脑里面是什么旗号
Jake: What logo is on your computer now
Katrina: 做音乐的
Katrina: For making music
Jake:旗号拔出来先
Jake: Remove the logo first
Jake:不要旗号
Jake: No logo
Katrina: 确实我觉得网易云唯一不足
Katrina: I think the only downside of NetEase Cloud
Katrina: 就是没有周杰伦
Katrina: Is that it doesn't have Jay Chou
Katrina: 就是你得切另一个软件
Katrina: You have to switch to another app
Lucia: 啊是
Lucia: Ah, yes
Katrina: 可是网易云上压根就没有
Katrina: But NetEase Cloud doesn't have it at all
Lucia: 网易云上压根就没啊OK
Lucia: NetEase Cloud doesn't have it at all, OK
Shure: 没有那个版权
Shure: They don't have the rights
Shure: 来吧随机播放
Shure: Alright, let's do shuffle play
Shure: Steam首先放哪个
Shure: Steam, which one to play first
Shure: 就先放你这个吧好吧
Shure: Let's play yours first, alright
Katrina: 然后你按随机看你这音效效果怎么样
Katrina: Then press shuffle and see how your sound effects turn out
Jake:7号
Jake: Number 7
Lucia: 谁的有谁的电话吗这是
Lucia: Whose phone is this, anyone's?
Jake:易一点对你你稍微难一点
Jake: Easier for you, a bit harder for you
Tasha: 啊我手机居然在这里
Tasha: Ah, my phone is actually here
Katrina: 贴的啥安康
Katrina: What's it posted, Ankang?
Jake:哈哈哈你从你从9号开始
Jake: Hahaha, start from number 9
Shure: 这是我原来乐队的名字
Shure: This was the name of my old band.
Jake:8号在一楼
Jake: Number 8 is on the first floor.
Jake:呃9号
Jake: Uh, number 9.
Katrina: 我们学校乐队叫hallowork
Katrina: Our school's band is called hallowork.
Jake:对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yes, skip to number 11.
Jake:然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: Then what you need to do is, for each floor...
Jake:就是按楼层
Jake: ...according to the floor.
Jake:这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor.
Katrina: 哇对味
Katrina: Wow, right on point.
Jake:哎这是一楼
Jake: Hey, this is the first floor.
Jake:这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor.
Katrina: 爽啦
Katrina: Cool.
Jake:然后我标一下
Jake: Then I'll mark it.
Jake:给我一个那个纸
Jake: Give me that paper.
Katrina: 地暗天黑都已无所谓
Katrina: It doesn't matter if the ground is dark and the sky is gloomy.
Katrina: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Katrina: Ah, why did you read out my screen name?
Katrina: 哈哈哈因为不愿醒来
Katrina: Hahaha, because I don't want to wake up.
Jake:呵为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Huh, why is it still on March 2nd?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited to change it.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:等到明年3月2号是吧
Jake: Wait until March 2nd next year, right?
Katrina: 等到什么时候再看下一场了再改
Katrina: Wait until then to see the next show and then change it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 对我看第一场
Katrina: Yeah, I watched the first show.
Katrina: 在武汉我抢到了前驱票
Katrina: In Wuhan, I got the advance tickets.
Katrina: 3月2号 哦
Katrina: March 2nd, oh.
Katrina: 那时候刚来学校一会
Katrina: Just started school then.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina: 但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina: 他现在嗓子已经回春很多了
Katrina: His voice has gotten so much better now.
Katrina: 他把那心乱肺的高音给飙上去
Katrina: He can hit those high notes effortlessly.
Jake:那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Then let's have hotpot.
Jake:然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And chat about you guys.
Katrina: 了OK
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 我要买一下我的东西
Katrina: I need to buy my stuff.
Jake:好让数据丰富起来
Jake: Alright, let's make the data richer.
Katrina: 今天可丰富了
Katrina: Today is already rich.
Katrina: 今天还那么多肢体动作
Katrina: So many movements today.
Jake:确实对现在也要丰富起来
Jake: Indeed, let's enrich it now too.
Alice:给你剪
Alice: Let me cut it for you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 哎我靠真好看
Katrina: Wow, this looks so good.
Lucia: 到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy.
Katrina: 其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, there are a lot of...
Katrina: 就是那种很有意思的做的家居品牌
Katrina: ...really interesting home decor brands now.
Lucia: 我选一个整屋定制哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm thinking of getting a whole house customization, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Katrina: 好好看哈哈
Katrina: It looks great, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Katrina: 你让杨老板给你报销
Katrina: Ask Jake to reimburse you.
Jake:外包是吧
Jake: Outsourcing, right?
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, yes, haha.
Jake:外包呵呵
Jake: Outsourcing, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Jake:500块钱 200外包
Jake: 500 bucks, 200 for outsourcing.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:全程外包
Jake: Full outsourcing.
Jake:不是不是VLC啊
Jake: Not VLC, no.
Jake:你这哪个VLC
Jake: Which VLC are you talking about?
Lucia: 因为这种对于我这个选择恐惧症来说
Lucia: Because for someone like me with choice anxiety...
Jake:你这不是VLC
Jake: This isn't VLC.
Lucia: 真的很难搞
Lucia: It's really hard to handle.
Katrina: 我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I also have a small balcony.
Katrina: 我阳台上可以放东西
Katrina: I can put things on my balcony.
Katrina: 非非无法抉择哦哦
Katrina: Fei Fei can't make a decision, oh oh.
Jake:哈哈哈学学
Jake: Haha, learn from it.
Jake:挺准的你
Jake: You're pretty accurate.
Katrina: 那个疯狂的人是我喔哦
Katrina: That crazy person is me, oh oh.
Jake:你腰部也低一点
Jake: Lower your waist a bit.
Jake:然后这个高一点
Jake: And raise this higher.
Tasha: 减无可减
Tasha: Can't cut any more.
Jake:我想想怎么办
Jake: Let me think about it.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because...
Jake:因为你这个硬盘也要放在这个地方
Jake: Because you need to place the hard drive here.
Jake:然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't let the hard drive fall.
Jake:你懂吗所以你行行行
Jake: Do you get it? So you... okay, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈对然后插上
Jake: Haha, yeah, then plug it in.
Katrina: 有一种岁月静好的感觉
Katrina: It feels so peaceful and serene.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They're working.
Katrina: 然后这边在放歌
Katrina: And over here, they're playing music.
Katrina: 这边在剪花
Katrina: Here, they're trimming flowers.
Shure: 我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'm cheering you on!
Shure: 我给你们跳yes okay
Shure: I'll do a "yes okay" dance for you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey.
Jake:睇嚟做得唔好
Jake: Looks like it's not done well.
Jake:对唔出
Jake: Can't match it.
Lucia: 我觉得他动作已经很得精髓了
Lucia: I think he already got the essence of the moves.
Jake:要不把碗洗了哈哈哈
Jake: How about washing the dishes, haha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:先生你好
Jake: Hello, sir.
Jake:卧槽哈哈哈你怎么弄的
Jake: What the heck, hahaha, how did you do that?
Jake:呃OK
Jake: Uh, OK.
Jake:那那你直接这样嘛
Jake: So, just do it like this.
Jake:你你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Jake:贴着贴哎
Jake: Stick it, stick it.
Jake:能能贴吗贴着吧
Jake: Can it stick? Just stick it.
Jake:这拿打着
Jake: Hold this and hit it.
Jake:不行歇着歇着好
Jake: No, take a break, take a break. Okay.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Jake:拿个工具
Jake: Get a tool.
Jake:等一下贴硬盘上 1 2
Jake: Wait, stick it on the hard drive. One, two.
Katrina: 天呐好多好看的都是要做手工
Katrina: Oh my god, so many pretty ones need to be handmade.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, it’s getting too extravagant.
Jake:教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Teaching foreigners to use Taobao is also good.
Jake:让他们羡慕去
Jake: Let them be envious.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform that can sponsor us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: So we can use them more.
Jake:这还有个帽子还戴着呢哈
Jake: There’s still a hat here, you know.
Lucia: 啊亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Ah, Amazon, right?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了不用教
Lucia: They already know how to use it, no need to teach.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 我要买几个摆在我那
Katrina: I want to buy a few to display at my place.
Jake:这就直接导
Jake: Just import it directly.
Jake:自然前面的数据都不太好
Jake: Naturally, the previous data wasn't very good.
Katrina: 爽
Katrina: Cool.
Jake:呃这个
Jake: Uh, this.
Jake:你们这个硬盘里面贴这个
Jake: Stick this inside the hard drive.
Jake:暗号是第二层
Jake: The code is the second level.
Jake:所以对对对
Jake: So, yes, yes, yes.
Jake:专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: Specifically for the Pro version, the second level.
Jake:然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: Then, according to each camera...
Jake:呃然后每一天
Jake: Uh, and then each day...
Alice:还满意吗
Alice: Are you satisfied?
Tasha: 可以呀谢谢
Tasha: Yes, thank you.
Jake:然后这个先上
Jake: Then, start with this.
Jake:先上这个盘对吧
Jake: Start with this dish, right?
Jake:插上了这边
Jake: Plug this in here.
Jake:如果我原来帮他插上了
Jake: If I had plugged it in before...
Jake:然后你现在没有
Jake: And now you don't have it...
Jake:他要可热化一下
Jake: It needs to be reheated.
Jake:贴的不太对是吧
Jake: It's not sticking well, right?
Jake:要不换个地方贴
Jake: How about we stick it somewhere else?
Katrina: 情人时总会
Katrina: Lovers' time always...
Jake:你往下贴贴
Jake: Stick it lower.
Jake:其实就好
Jake: That should be fine.
Jake:哈哈哈还是有点事
Jake: Haha, there's still something wrong.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake:其实还行
Jake: Actually, it's okay.
Jake:这个线不会回窝就这样
Jake: This line won't go back, just like that.
Jake:so so计算机
Jake: So, so, computer...
Jake:计算机什么东西
Jake: What about the computer?
Jake:管理对
Jake: Manage it, right.
Jake:呃硬盘
Jake: Uh, hard drive...
Jake:磁盘管理
Jake: Disk management...
Jake:呃格瑞化塔
Jake: Uh, formatting...
Jake:这个出了吗好
Jake: Did this come out? Okay.
Jake:啊确定
Jake: Ah, confirm.
Jake:一路确定下去
Jake: Confirm all the way.
Jake:你这没有
Jake: You don't have it.
Jake:那那再拍一次
Jake: Then, take another shot.
Jake:把这个关了
Jake: Turn this off.
Jake:重拍一次
Jake: Shoot it again.
Jake:对好
Jake: Yes, good.
Shure: 这锅是
Shure: This pot is...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha...
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay.
Tasha: 什么都没干
Tasha: Didn't do anything.
Alice:那
Alice: Then...
Lucia: 你做作业
Lucia: Do your homework.
Lucia: 你放心的做作业
Lucia: Just focus on your homework.
Jake:好结束了
Jake: Alright, it's done.
Jake:然后放对
Jake: Then put it right.
Lucia: 啊好难过死
Lucia: Ah, this is so difficult.
Jake:一般放个瓶
Jake: Usually put a bottle.
Jake:左边左边右边
Jake: Left, left, right.
Lucia: 啊你剪的这个好漂亮呀
Lucia: Ah, you cut this so beautifully.
Alice:这都是我捡的
Alice: I picked all of these.
Lucia: 啊这也好看
Lucia: Ah, this one looks great too.
Lucia: 这面看特别有层次感
Lucia: This side has a really nice texture.
Lucia: 啊你的这个也还没开
Lucia: Ah, yours hasn't bloomed yet either.
Lucia: 我那个也是
Lucia: Mine too.
Lucia: 都还没开
Lucia: None of them have bloomed yet.
Alice:欣赏一下
Alice: Just appreciate it.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:是修剪了一遍
Jake: It's been trimmed once.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:修剪了狠狠的修剪了一遍
Alice:也没有还很一般般
Alice: It's still pretty average.
Jake:确实好看了很多
Jake: It definitely looks much better.
Lucia: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Lucia: I'm curious, what symbols did everyone draw?
Alice:我给他画的翅膀
Alice: I drew wings for him.
Jake:翅膀但是画的有点丑
Jake: Wings, but they look a bit ugly.
Alice:但是画的有点丑
Alice: But they look a bit ugly.
Jake:还没写写一下
Jake: Haven't written yet, write something.
Alice:我是个星
Alice: I drew a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I drew a little sun.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字
Lucia: Ah, Yuxuan just wrote his name.
Katrina: 哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, aromatherapy.
Katrina: 我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a little aromatherapy set.
Lucia: 买一串星星灯
Lucia: Buy a string of star lights.
Lucia: 直接给房间上挂一圈就完事了
Lucia: Just hang them around the room, that's it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这是我的
Jake: This is mine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 火
Katrina: Fire.
Katrina: 哈哈哈受不
Katrina: Hahaha, can't handle it.
Lucia: 他是什么花
Lucia: What kind of flower is he?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 哇很直接了当
Lucia: Wow, very straightforward.
Jake:就是只要NB4 其他的都不用
Jake: Just need NB4, nothing else.
Jake:不用啊哎
Jake: No need, hey.
Jake:人呢他会吗
Jake: Can he do it?
Jake:尼玛哈哈哈你咋跑了
Jake: Damn, hahaha, why did you run?
Jake:我回来了
Jake: I'm back.
Jake:哈哈哈你结束
Jake: Hahaha, you're done.
Nicous: 我那熬着已经结束了
Nicous: I'm already done with that.
Jake:尼玛不让你
Jake: Damn, don't let you.
Jake:哈哈哈 15十五号
Jake: Hahaha, fifteen, number fifteen.
Jake:十六号秒
Jake: Sixteen seconds.
Jake:你这是不是
Jake: Is this right?
Jake:哎其实没毛病
Jake: Actually, it's fine.
Katrina: 花果香
Katrina: Floral and fruity.
Jake:哈哈哈多少慢了点
Jake: Hahaha, a bit slow.
Jake:只是慢了
Jake: Just a bit slow.
Jake:有读卡器可以买读卡器
Jake: If you have a card reader, you can buy one.
Jake:就一个硬盘啊
Jake: Just a hard drive, right?
Jake:但是你速度我不知道
Jake: But I don't know your speed.
Jake:你两个一起倒速度会有变化吗
Jake: Will the speed change if you copy both at the same time?
Jake:呃应该就是很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Uh, it should be a very meticulous naming method.
Shure: 这个面糊会不会堵下水道呢
Shure: Will this batter clog the drain?
Jake:是你呃你现在怎么命名呢
Jake: So, uh, how do you name it now?
Jake:你现在就直接拖进去是吧
Jake: You just drag it in directly, right?
Jake:对对对我操
Jake: Yeah, yeah, damn.
Jake:你他妈太粗暴了
Jake: You're too rough.
Jake:对对对太太太粗暴了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, too, too, too rough.
Jake:来来来这个法2好吧
Jake: Come on, come on, this method 2, okay?
Jake:呃那个你是几号相机
Jake: Uh, which camera number are you?
Jake:那你写个一一一新建文件加一
Jake: Then you write one, one, one, create a new file and add one.
Jake:呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, then go in.
Jake:进去新建一个202404
Jake: Go in and create a new one, 202404.
Jake:从15开始的其实对151617
Jake: Starting from fifteen actually, yeah, fifteen, sixteen, seventeen.
Jake:你直接建吧
Jake: You just create it directly.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then,
Jake:到时候你看他创建日期是什么时候
Jake: When the time comes, see the creation date.
Jake:你就往里面涂
Jake: Just put it in.
Jake:每一个视频
Jake: Each video.
Jake:他有自己的充电日期
Jake: He has his own charging schedule.
Lucia: 偏强
Lucia: It's quite strong.
Jake:快速干嘛啊
Jake: Why so fast?
Jake:啊对这这够快了
Jake: Oh right, this is fast enough.
Jake:比迈克快多了
Jake: Much faster than Mike.
Jake:哎迈克也很快
Jake: Well, Mike is pretty fast too.
Jake:写个patter
Jake: Write a pattern.
Jake:你可以你可以建很多
Jake: You can, you can build many.
Jake:你可以建到22
Jake: You can build up to 22.
Jake:然后这个里面再写相机的那个
Jake: Then write the camera's info inside.
Jake:相机的编号
Jake: The camera's serial number.
Jake:对你编号在啊
Jake: Yeah, you have the serial number, right?
Jake:哎你是二人吗
Jake: Hey, are you on the second floor?
Jake:22楼吗没有没有没有你
Jake: 22nd floor? No, no, no, you're not.
Jake:你在我最外层
Jake: You're on my outermost layer.
Jake:就这个你要你要
Jake: So, this, you need to...
Jake:拖到一个
Jake: Drag it to one.
Jake:再到20号
Jake: Then to the 20th.
Jake:呃没关系
Jake: Uh, no worries.
Jake:见到17也行
Jake: Meeting at 17 is fine.
Jake:见到17吧
Jake: Meet at 17 then.
Jake:然后我就把
Jake: And then I'll...
Jake:对你看到日期
Jake: Yeah, you saw the date.
Jake:你看日期了吗
Jake: Did you see the date?
Jake:9号相机
Jake: Camera 9.
Jake:你的一号相机
Jake: Your camera 1.
Jake:你的壳还在吧
Jake: The shell is still there, right?
Jake:他从9号相机开始
Jake: Starting from camera 9.
Shure: 搞定
Shure: Done.
Shure: 全倍亮跟你讲
Shure: All set, I'm telling you.
Katrina: 买那个呢这买那个啧啧
Katrina: Buying that one, buying this one, tsk tsk.
Jake:不用不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:对啊我我觉得不应该这么办了
Jake: Yeah, I think we shouldn't do it this way.
Jake:气死我了
Jake: It's driving me crazy.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Jake:我原来想一个小时在这转一圈搞定
Jake: I originally thought it would take an hour to go around and get it done.
Jake:他妈头崩了
Jake: It's giving me a headache.
Shure: 啊搞定
Shure: Ah, done.
Jake:是我原来还没有买这种卡
Jake: Yeah, I didn't buy this kind of card before.
Jake:所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So I have to insert it into the GoPro.
Jake:就是把那个充电线给插电脑上
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake:然后开始倒
Jake: And then start transferring.
Jake:然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: Then run one by one.
Jake:就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: The original plan was to push this small table around.
Jake:然后推着到处跑
Jake: And push it everywhere.
Jake:然后碰到傻逼了
Jake: And then we ran into an idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's too difficult.
Shure: 在点什么
Shure: What are you clicking on?
Jake:太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: Too slow, it's both slow and troublesome.
Jake:they are就两两个人
Jake: They are just two people.
Jake:好歹一人一层啊
Jake: At least one person per floor.
Jake:我他妈一人15个
Jake: I'm doing 15 people by myself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 我一会在上面吃还是下面吃火锅
Shure: Should I have hotpot upstairs or downstairs?
Katrina: ；上面
Katrina: Upstairs.
Jake:我在下面吃
Jake: I'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 啊啥
Lucia: What?
Lucia: 我们是在上面还是下面
Lucia: Are we eating upstairs or downstairs?
Katrina: 现在在shoping
Katrina: Currently shopping.
Lucia: 如果在下面的话我就再搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: If we're eating downstairs, I'll bring down a couple of chairs.
Jake:小品
Jake: Sketch.
Katrina: shoping中
Katrina: Shopping.
Jake:好好在下面吃
Jake: Alright, let's eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Fine.
Jake:呃我想一下在下面时
Jake: Uh, let me think, downstairs...
Jake:可以在下面去
Jake: We can go downstairs.
Jake:你出来被拍吧
Jake: You come out and get filmed.
Jake:你就给点
Jake: Just give a little.
Jake:你给点素材出来拍
Jake: Provide some material to shoot.
Jake:给你你的座位嘛座位
Jake: Here's your seat, your seat.
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sitting on the floor.
Shure: 大象席地而坐
Shure: The elephant sits on the floor.
Jake:一个吉他
Jake: A guitar.
Jake:还是被扫过的
Jake: It's still been scanned.
Jake:这是一个赛博系统
Jake: This is a cyber system.
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Is it really?
Shure: 他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life now.
Jake:对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yes, but it's not cyber.
Jake:你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure: 那也就是现在
Shure: So that means now...
Jake:呵呵哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha haha haha haha!
Shure: 就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: So, someone just appeared out of nowhere?
Shure: 有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吗
Shure: And there's a guitar here making sounds on its own?
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我们差差31234567然后我们有几个人
Lucia: We have 31234567 and then how many people do we have?
Lucia: 八个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, let's grab one more.